and we start with breaking news a really  chaotic scene up in the northeast valley  i'm brian loftis i'm denise valdez this  is all unfolding right now near east  cheyenne and las vegas boulevard madison  kimbrough is live with the breaking  details  yeah this started as an argument between  two people around three this afternoon  and you can take a look as we're here at  las brisas de cheyenne apartments police  say the fight escalated into a shooting  between both people we know three people  are now injured they were taken to umc  no word on any deaths you can see a  heavy police presence here at cheyenne  and walnut and it's a very active scene  continues to be if you're headed this  way you should avoid the area again this  is cheyenne and walnut now police say  that the road should open up within an  hour or so so that's good news if you  are traveling this direction but if you  have to come this way try to find an  alternate route reporting live madison  kimbrough live local now